foreign
is a very giant Fantastical RPG open
world RPG from Bethesda softworks I I
think a lot of like salty old uh 30 year
old PC Gamers you might find a bit more
reverence for Morrowind among types like
like me but it's still like regarded as
one of the all-time greats among many
groups regardless when the game came out
I I like I ran home and I was sitting
there all day waiting for it to come
through the less walks queued up at
midnight to get it and I
called in sick from University the
the day it came out and I bought a copy
of Assassin's Creed Revelations and I
bought a copy of Skyrim because they
came out that same crew members the same
day or same week and I went in and the
guy was like
well you're gonna enjoy one of these
more than the other and I don't think he
was talking about Assassin's Creed and I
literally logged on and made my
character and I'd already sort of
written down and planned out how that
might look and what kind of character it
would be every time I rerolled I think
maybe I'll do it different this time
maybe I'll go magic maybe I'll go potion
craft nope every single time it was
ranged attacks and sneaky I think the
only build available in Skyrim is
stealthy Archer like I don't I don't
think anyone plays anything else because
it's just that's just the funnest way to
play it obviously it's the meme of like
stealth Archer every run inevitably
falls into a stealth Archer run when my
first build didn't first build I was
like
I'm big scary I'm strong I want things
that are sharp I'm gonna hit you with
them I don't know if I do have one in
general because ultimately you gotta go
with the flow of how the game is built
feel like any game that I can role play
in I'm going to be that character uh so
if a quest just doesn't fit uh I'm not
gonna do it so I didn't do the Mages
Quest I didn't do the Dark Brotherhood
in my first playthrough I did the
companions because it felt right I guess
I just like to make characters that feel
very real
if I start out trying to build a
character
my story usually winds up taking him in
some other direction
anytime you try to write a story the
characters seem to take over
and it's the same way in the game making
a story
so I might start out trying to build an
archery type but he's going to wind up
being a warrior in spite of myself
first thing I think of when I think of
Skyrim is the first time I played the
game I remember booting it up okay you
have the intro sequence I guess once you
got past that and you were first able to
exit the cave and look around the kind
of world and the possibilities that were
in front of you I just remember that
being absolutely mesmerized by that
moment as soon as you reach Riverwood
after following the first NPC depending
who you side with you're immediately
sidetracked by like several different
quests oh the beautiful scenery all the
different biomes all the places to go
the Northern Lights
the night sky wandering through the
snowy Tundra and kind of look at the
swelling sound of the atmosphere
distraction kind of comes to mind
wherever I think of Skyrim and just not
being able to especially like the first
time I played like follow the main quest
line at all honestly the main story in
Skyrim is probably the weakest part of
the game if I'm honest I would do the
main story up to the point where I got
the shouts unlocked and then it was like
so long story man you're not playing
Skyrim correctly unless it crashes to
desktop after a bunch of mods that you
have installed and if you wander away
from the main quest for 70 hours and
then all of a sudden remember five years
later that oh I never finished the main
question Skyrim I should knock that out
I don't know what the narrative is like
you're Dragonborn I don't know if I've
ever
strictly played all the way through the
game from beginning to end through all
the quests cause I role play and make up
my own stories every series is a
different kind of story I tell you're
immediately thrown so many other things
like you're in a civil war there's you
meet the companions on the way to
Whiterun who are killing a giant so
there's like several different guilds
you can suddenly sort of walk into
I think based on Oblivion and loving the
Dark Brotherhood questline I was like
where's the Dark Brotherhood everyone
knows it's the best storyline the way
that like characters like you'll hear
characters talk about and Whisper about
it and like like if you're not really
familiar with Elder Scrolls or previous
Elder Scrolls games the idea of the Dark
Brotherhood hearing it in such a way how
it unravels in Skyrim particular is is
so mysterious and I'm a sucker for
Mysteries doing the whole wedding
assassination with pushing the statue
and even killing the emperor like that's
a big kind of timeline changing event
potentially if you think through the law
ramifications of it it's got ups and
downs it's got the portrayals that you
kind of expect from the Dark Brotherhood
story after after Oblivion it was nice
to see some returning characters and uh
kind of know that things inevitably were
going to go really really bad for that
end of murderers I like how crazy some
of the characters and the interactions
they they were having with you it seems
like when the writers of an Elder
Scrolls game have you doing nasty evil
stuff they uh they they tend to have a
little more fun with the writing
um you also get a sick ass [ __ ]
amount out of it because that thing this
was like basically unkillable and and
scale mountains that no horse should
ever be able to
I think the thing with Skyrim is that
like the moments that are the most
memorable and like some of my favorite
moments with it are the ones that are
just completely random like we're just a
dragon lands on you
I think whenever you ask someone about
their favorite moment or their first
memorable moment in uh Skyrim it's all
like 80 of the time it's gonna be like a
giant sending you to space
for my house in solitude because you
have the the display cases that open up
I remember collecting a piece of armor
and a shield from every city and it
looked cool but I remember as soon as
you walked into my house the frame rate
would drop to about nine that moment
where you're kind of escaping everything
and you hear that the dragon's coming
and then the dragon just lands on top of
that Tower in my head though now it's
like this bastardized memory where I
have Macho Man Randy Savage going like
his voice lines because of that mod
becoming so famous
yeah
I I definitely have fond memories of
loading up so many mods into that game
that it would uh crash to desktop on
start until I finally get it right which
is also like the best way to play an
Elder Scrolls game all these sort of um
modding projects with hundreds of people
working on them for free you know like
these these people are doing incredible
work off their own time
um creating projects that the community
uh to this day like extremely excited
for uh whenever whenever Beth Ester
reveals a game from here on out people
are are gonna be thinking of two games
in their mind when they look at those
videos they're gonna be thinking of the
vanilla product they get out of the
packaging and then what's gonna happen a
few months or years down the road when
the thing starts crashing the desktop
because you have too many mods put on it
[Music]
Skyrim in general just has a very
consistently good soundtrack uh
throughout it I use it I use it for a
very long time to fall asleep to
um so there's the very last track on
like the Spotify version of the
soundtrack is a simply Skyrim
atmospheres and that was what I played
for nights upon nights upon nights to
fall asleep to in fact like when they do
that like Spotify wrap up at the end of
the year it's always like most listened
to is Skyrim atmospheres when you're out
just wandering around in the out in the
planes that music is so wonderful
[Music]
oh
[Music]
but I just love the Dragonborn song it's
not one that I'm going to relax to but
every time I hear it it gets me so hyped
up even though I've heard it before or I
hear like an Orchestral Version of it
I'm like
this is still so good it's such a good
song but I've got quite a special
relationship I suppose with the Skyrim
music because since leaving Gamespot
with my production company double jump
we've actually filmed orchestras playing
this music when I was in London Bethesda
at one point invited me to go and see
the live orchestra music of Skyrim
um and that was it was like childhood
coming back and I had Shivers on my
spine just listening to the music
[Music]
it's almost 11 years old and it's still
a thing it's still going it's still a
vibrant modding Community
um and that that longevity is is part of
its Legacy I think the legacy of Skyrim
is that it brought so many more people
into
the Elder Scrolls
for for one reason or another it
attracted more fans more a bigger fan
base and I know a lot of people who
aren't really Gamers
uh who played Skyrim and absolutely fell
in love with Skyrim or for some people
that game made them start playing games
so it's a cultural tour divorce is uh
it's like the Star Wars almost for for
the generation of kids who grew up with
it everyone played uh Skyrim is one of
one of the more popular selling games I
think it's been ported to everything
Skyrim's Legacy is the fact it just will
not die because the community no matter
what just keep it alive
um through modding music fan art
creating content podcast Theory videos
like uh Mike the liar being acotosh
um you know crazy things like this that
we can still debate today it took the
idea of an open world RPG things that
had been done before it was done before
in the Elder Scrolls series with
Oblivion and Morrowind and all the other
Jazz before it but it was able to
package it in a way that was so
approachable and so inspiring that it
essentially changed the way open world
RPGs were made going forward I don't
think it's a a coincidence necessarily
that oftest Skyrim's massive success
because Skyrim was a super successful
game it was kind of like for better or
worse because there are often examples
where this was the wrong decision but
every game was putting this huge
emphasis on open world without something
like Skyrim games like The Witcher 3
wouldn't be the way they are I don't
think open World Games in general would
be the way they are I don't think games
like Far Cry would have expanded and
evolved into what they are today
whether whatever you feel about Skyrim
now because it kind of has this negative
reputation in a lot of ways just because
it's been re-released so many times I
don't think that should take away from
what Skyrim did and from how many people
Skyrim has affected in combination with
Oblivion tomorrow ended absolutely
contributed to uh me having a greater
interest in ancient mythology and heroic
epics and uh uh songs that tell stories
about strong men beating up monsters
it's gotten me into something that I
really love and it's helped me in
telling stories I have always since I
was a little girl
wanted to tell stories and this has
opened up the world of telling stories
to me because now I can tell the story
on the screen and don't have to just sit
and write write all right it's helped me
grow in my writing which is strange
because it's a game play but it's helped
me to grow in my writing and
storytelling the impact Skyrim has had
on me is almost immeasurable in the
sense that it's matched my career in the
games industry like completely became
synonymous with me and Seb doing top 5
scarring mods of the week while we were
at Gamespot and then he and I left
Gamespot to start a company and then we
work with Bethesda around Skyrim filming
the concerts and filming the live
recordings so the game is is like has
matched my career along the way and it's
it's just so important to me as a result
it it has obviously changed my life I
mean it allowed me to become a YouTuber
and to kind of uh achieve the job that I
wanted to do since I was a kid in high
school that I get to obsess over what I
love and do it with my friends
and I mean what more can you ask for you
know
I think my final parting thoughts for
Skyrim and for anyone who wants to play
Skyrim or has even played Skyrim before
don't be afraid to try it again there
are so many different ways to play the
game there is no way to play it wrong if
you're speedrunning if you're
role-playing or if you're just playing
through for you know completion's sake
there is no wrong way to play the game
but there are many ways a lot of people
come to me and they're like should I do
this or this or build my character like
that or that I'm like don't watch any of
my videos just go and play the game I
love games these days push you forward
quickly
but there's a lot to Skyrim where some
of the best moments come from just
taking a moment to smell the roses look
at the beautiful scenery take time to
engage in the conversations instead of
skipping through them
have a good time explore don't feel like
you need to go through your quest log
the whole time don't just go from Quest
explore find out places for your own
self don't don't
follow a quest line
my party thoughts on Skyrim is that you
don't really part ways with it at least
I didn't because if I did I wouldn't
still be playing it you don't beat
Skyrim you play it forever
that's that's how I feel about it
[Music]
becomes so addicted and I can't do
anything else
my housework goes down the tubes I don't
quilt anymore uh I don't read constantly
all the time like I did I don't want to
go in the kitchen and cook me anything
to eat because I don't want to take the
time
it's an addiction I guess it's better
than a drug addiction but still it's an
addiction